alright first off you need to know I
haven't read the book it like I have
sequentially in the course the past
couple years picked up the book read a
bit put it I'm like 1/3 of the way
through but nothing from it chapter 2
yet really except for you know the
introduction to the adult characters the
point of this is to inform you that if I
bring something up in this review and
I'm like well that didn't really work
for me if the answer you want to give
when you get on your keyboard is well
that's how it was in the book please
reference the beginning of this review
right here alright let's do it
[Music]
it's Chapter two so in chapter 2 is the
sequel to it it's actually half of the
it book that book is as big as a Bible
so they're like yeah we're splitting
that movie into two halves the first
movie we'll call it chapter one is the
losers Club and they're all kids they
take on penny wise and now this is the
sequel 27 years later all the kids are
grown up they got to go back to Derry
take on penny wise again hopefully for
good first off there's part of me that's
like let's talk about the casting later
but the casting in this movie is so good
I'm gonna talk about it now because my
god like the adult versions of the kids
are perfect it's like wit time travels
real I don't think I've ever seen
casting in a story a movie a show and
anything where the adults have to be the
adult versions of kids that you also see
and it works so well
look the adults in this movie would
swear the adult versions of all the kids
to stand out is you've already heard it
Bill Hader is the stand-out which
completely makes sense because Bill
Hader as Ritchie is to stand out in it
chapter tip in wolfhard as Ritchie was a
standout in it chapter one so that just
kind of does make sense but everyone
does a great job in this movie I'm not
gonna list off all their names
I really should out of respect I still
want to have my fine hold on give me a
second but the ones I know James McAvoy
Jessica Chastain also did a great job or
James Ransa or is that ransone or Ren's
son ransone pretty sure though he was
great Jay Ryan Isaiah Mustafa that's a
sweet last name I want bill has named
Mustafa
sounds like Mufasa wait a minute is he
the Old Spice guy
I need a minute some things blow my mind
when I'm reviewing movies that was that
anyhow everyone does a really good job
like everyone in this movie all the
adults they brought the same energy that
the kids brought but just matured it and
now it's 27 years later so they have
adult damage it completely works I will
say this movie is long like it's a it's
almost three hours long and even though
it's almost three hours long and you do
feel yes this is a three hour long
movies not like it flies by like that
was like an hour and a half right what
three hours crazy pacing now it feels
like a long movie is one of the things
it chapter one has over it chapter two
it chapter one I could just pop in and
watch any time just like all right watch
it watch it watch it great awesome it
chapter two I feel like it's one of
those movies like I gotta be in the mood
to invest that kind of time and energy
just the way it is like I feel like it
chapter one is it's a contained movie it
chapter two is a longer movie that
requires more of an investment and it
does require you watching it chapter one
first but it chapter two is in line with
it chapter one it chapter one was a
character movie it wasn't just like all
of a group of kids getting terrorized by
this evil clown get away from the
keyboards and always not really a clown
in Chapter two is also a character piece
and all that this clown is really
actively coming after these adults all
the time yeah there are definitely some
scenes where he does but actually most
of the Pennywise stuff is done in
flashbacks there are flashbacks where
they kind of fill in some of the gaps a
bit chapter one with the kids again it
shows like Oh penny wise was coming
after them in these scenes that weren't
actually in the movie I guess the kids
were Dee aged because they're at that
age where it's like oh it's been two
years they look like they look like
different humans now so I guess they use
CGI 2d age them I'm gonna be honest with
you 100% I didn't even notice like I
didn't even notice I wasn't like wow
their faces look weird it's just they
looked at y'all it might be because
there's some other CGI scenes in the
movie room like that is really CGI so my
brain in my eyes were like that's so CGI
the faces not don't even look CGI
business as usual maybe that's is that
rule of contrast happening right there
but I was really impressed with the fact
that this movie brought heart when it
needed to bring heart brought the tears
when it needed to bring the tears in
contrast to the fact that it's also
really funny I didn't expect that I'm
watching this movie I was like this is
one of the funniest movies I've seen
this year I didn't expect that in it
after to not to say it doesn't have
creepy things it might be because I'm
older now it's like I know this thing
doesn't exist I'm not gonna be laying in
bed and this this evil things gonna
happen and turn into something I fear
and try to kill me I'm sure aging helps
in that regard when watching movies like
this I didn't I wasn't that scared there
was some intense scenes yeah it's like
ooh drowning ah
drowning in blood all of this is to say
that it chapter two is essentially
taking you on a character journey it's
an odyssey with these characters not
there to scare you it's there to have
you be fulfilled and see them go through
this journey see them relive something
see them being faced with the fact it's
like you're adults
you all have driver's licenses you can
leave like that's the thing I'm glad
they touched on Slyke they're not kids
or not they're not stuck in this town I
really like that so I like the fact that
it chapter two like it chapter one is a
character journey you have with these
characters you saw them as kids you see
them now as adults and when you have
chapter 1 and chapter 2 stacked with
each other you have yourself a pretty
fulfilling what would it be 5 our epic
just about 5 hours long that's pretty
awesome
I actually feel like even though this
movie is about three hours long I feel
like there's an hour of this movie
missing I feel like there's just an hour
somewhere it's like there are gaps in
there there are things that were alluded
to and things that were foreshadowed
that you didn't actually see come to
fruition one quick one I'll touch on is
there's a character in this movie and I
thought they were gonna do so much more
with this character and really nothing
really with this character I mean it's
one of those characters where if you
took this character out of the movie
entirely the movie wouldn't change at
all this character first and foremost is
one of the main reasons for my
disclaimer at the beginning of this
review who really I thought they're
gonna do so much more with this
character maybe in the hypothetical for
our cut that may or may not exist I feel
like might exist maybe that character
does more but for this one not really
there were a couple other things I was
like at but that's that spoiler
territory senator that here in the end
I'll say it chapter two I really enjoyed
it I think it chapter one's the better
movie I feel like it chapter two is a
great companion piece of the first one
you put them together you have yourself
a solid epic I will say it chapter 2 was
a great time no alcohol required if I'm
giving my fantasy if there's something I
want to see I would love to see a cut
where it's it chapter one and it chapter
two interwoven with each other like
we're like this it's just the it's
supercut it's just called it lettuce I
guess is what the first movies called
whatever I'd like to see that like Kill
Bill the whole bloody affair that I
heard about like 15 years ago that just
still has not happened okay so it
chapter two have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]